mtpro Mac Mini or M2 Max Max studio well
I did a ton of testing with two of each
of these models so this is going to be
the ultimate comparison and there are a
lot of differences both in terms of
features and in terms of thermals and
how these run now at the base I have a
thirteen hundred dollar M2 Pro which is
the cheapest version you can buy and
then I have an upgraded one that's
around two thousand dollars if you spec
it up and then we have a two thousand
dollar base Max studio as well as an
upgraded one if you want to get the full
graphics performance and faster ssds now
as for those ssds both Macs come with
512 gigs base and as you guys could see
if you upgrade to one terabyte the speed
gets a lot faster but what is very weird
is that the Mac Studios one terabyte is
actually slower than the Mac minis maybe
it's because of the ssds that are used
on not sure but we do see that little
bit of a difference and I would
recommend upgrading to one terabyte to
get those much faster speeds and the
other weird thing is if you take the
tiny Mac Mini and you upgrade it to 32
gigs of RAM and the full performance the
price tag is the same as the Mac Studio
but you don't get 10 gigabit Ethernet so
if you add that it's actually a hundred
dollars more expensive than the Mac
Studio so let's see which Mac you should
buy and which spec depending on what you
do now before I get into all of the
performance numbers I want to tell you
guys the exterior differences obviously
the Mac Mini is so much smaller and that
is pretty nice but with that you don't
get those extra two USBC ports on the
front and the SD card reader which I
think is killer to have and we use ours
all the time both Macs have four
Thunderbolt ports and an HDMI on the
back but the mini supports up to three
displays compared to 5 live on the Mac
Studio now who's going to use five I
don't know but with the mini if you do
high resolution displays for example at
8K you could just use one where on the
studio you could do an 8K and two 6ks or
more so if they're a little bit lower
resolution also 240Hz so it's a lot more
powerful the studio can also have 64
gigs of RAM if you want to spend the
extra where the minis capped at 32 but I
think not a lot of people that are
looking at this budget are going to want
to get that which is why I also am
looking at the 1300 mini to show you
guys how that compares starting off with
geekbench 6 as far as single core they
are very close with the studios being
just slightly faster and then looking at
multi-core the base mini is about 20
slower than the other ones but it also
costs way less so that seems like a
great deal now for General use the
performance is about the same both in
speedometer 2.0 which tests well web
browsing performance and we also tested
out figma which is kind of like a web
design based app and here we tested the
project brought To Us by 500 designs one
of the best studios in California and
the smoothness is the same across all of
them even the Mac Pro M2 Ultra that we
tested you get a little bit of stutters
but in general everything loads fairly
quickly and then exporting this high
resolution website with 12 layers as you
see the speeds are practically identical
and this does push your system a lot so
for web-based applications even the 1300
spec does great now in terms of graphics
performance I tested out geekbench 6
metal and you guys could see the spread
right here the interesting thing is
upgrading for 200 bucks more to the 38
core M2 Max that only gets about eight
percent more performance than the two
thousand dollars back and then the base
1300 dollar one it's only about 10
slower than our much more expensive
upgraded Mac Studio so these two options
seem like a great value now I also
tested out 3dmark Wildlife that does
purely gaming performance instead of
compute and here I would say that the
200 extra for the upgraded Mt Max does
give you quite a good value and then the
two Mac minis are close enough to not
warrant that extra money now as far as
full CPU performance in cinebench well
here you guys could see that the base
model cheapest Mac Mini does fall off a
fair bit but the other ones are close
and it's interesting that the Mt Pro
actually consistently scored a little
bit higher than the studios I looked at
the power usage between these models and
you guys could see kind of scales but
the M2 Pro uses a bit more power which
is why it scores more and that is weird
now when you load up the CPU all the way
way this makes a lot of heat so how does
a tiny mini compare to the studio the
fan in there when we tore down is really
small whereas the studios is massive and
it is heavy well the Mac Mini the M2 Pro
maxed out likes to run at 100 degrees
Celsius with the fan running really slow
whereas the studio the highest I saw got
was 69 degrees Celsius with the fans at
idle so both of these are silent but the
studio runs extremely cool even Under
full load whereas Apple likes the mini
to run hot but quiet so if you're
concerned about fan noise don't be but
if you want your system to run really
cool the studio is the way to go now as
far as xcode performance here the three
more expensive machines are practically
identical and then the cheapest one well
it's not far off I think waiting that
extra 15 seconds it's not a deal breaker
and this is a tougher project xco just
runs so well on Apple silicon so you can
save a bit of money or put that into
more RAM now as far as logic use in our
new logic Benchmark which you guys can
look up all the plugins and stuff it
uses yes they are very similar with the
base one being a little bit off but the
performance is so good once again I want
to say if you do this you can save the
money unless you need extra ports now in
terms of blender this is where I saw a
massive difference here is the BMW test
the Mac Studios absolutely destroy the
Mac Mini this thing has some updates in
terms of how it deals with memory and it
makes a huge difference but the weird
thing was for the simple test the
studios even the upgraded GPU didn't
really make a big difference now going
to a much tougher test here I thought
the unbend M2 Max would go ahead and it
did but ever so slightly which is
absolutely crazy but if you spend the
same money on an M2 Pro Max studio all
upgraded it's half the performance you
do not want to make this mistake now for
the photo editors in Lightroom I
exported my standard 50 high resolution
edited Ros to JPEG and here you guys see
we do see a difference but only compared
to the base Mac Mini and it is not huge
now if we were going to do like a 500
test the numbers get larger but because
we don't have throttling they would
scale the same but if you go for more
images like high resolution like for
example in Photoshop I did my HDR
Panorama well here the base Mac Mini
really falls behind and that's when it
is worth upgrading but as far as the Mac
Studio well it performs very similar now
for the video editors you want to pay
attention here as far as doing simple
things like stabilizing the Mac Mini
really keeps up well even though has
worse graphics performance but when we
go to export a standard five minute
project the studios are the same but so
much faster than the Mac Mini because
they have dual encoders and that helps a
ton now all of these have prores
decoders and encoders which is amazing
but you guys could see that the Mac
Studio does come ahead because it has
slightly better ones and then it has a
more graphics performance now I will
argue that even the 1300r Mac Mini does
such a fast speed that you're not going
to have many issues the only difference
will come in if you're pushing maybe 8K
or multiple streams you might know that
it's a bit but I would be happy even
with the base M2 Pro now looking at AK
red raw bam that is a much bigger bread
and the upgraded Mac Mini compared to
the base Mac Studio that price tag is
the same or even more if you get 10gb
ethernet and the Mac Studio is a lot
faster and then here when we're dealing
with AK raw you want to spend that extra
200 bucks on the upgraded Graphics
because it is well worth that extra
money and to really push the graphics in
terms of raw video performance
intervention resolve I looked at
denoising this 4K Blackmagic raw footage
and here you guys can see the frames per
second now only the upgraded Mac Studio
can actually run it in real time which
is amazing for basically two thousand
dollars plus 200 bucks to be able to do
this my 15 000 Mac Pro could not do this
so the performance is mind-blowing but
here the upgraded Mac Mini really sucks
and the bass one is just slightly slower
so basically what we we learned for
video editing is if you do simple tasks
well if you care about encoding speed
you still want to get the Mac Studio and
then when you're doing tougher video
editing well that is where you really
really need to get the Mac Studio so I
would just say for video editors you
want the Mac Studio so that is the end
of my performance test so now I just
want to give you guys some overall
recommendations I think that for most
people it is just worth getting the
either the 1300 Mac Mini maybe upgrading
gram if you want it or getting the two
thousand dollar Mac Studio forget about
upgrading to the unbend M2 Pro and
adding on more storage and RAM it is
just a bad deal at this point with the
new Mac Studios that came out and then
if you do a lot of video editing that's
tough then you might want to upgrade and
get the extra Graphics but if you're
doing 3D design and you're on a budget
or we just want to get one that's sold
off the shelf for two thousand bucks
that is the best bang for the buck
um computer from Apple that I think that
you can get right now if you need extra
performance and then a 1300 spec that is
also a really killer value I would say
avoid upgrading the M2 Pro for most
people just go for the Mac Studio and
then not a lot of people need to upgrade
the Mac Studio now if you're wondering
about the M2 Ultra Max studio and how
that compares to M2 Max well that is
where the performance differences change
and we also have some other changes so
that's going to be a whole nother video
if you guys want to watch that click
that Circle above if you want to get
some great deals check out the links
below check out one of those videos
right over there this has been Max and
I'll see you in the next one
foreign